[Musique]
bonjour vous êtes d'emphase au caddie
avec ce matin le directeur du campus
caraïbéen des arts audry liseron monfils
bonjour bonjour alors l'école l'odyssée
la coupe le campus caribéen des arts
excusez moi c'est l'école supérieure
d'enseignement artistique de la
martinique
un établissement qui fait d'ailleurs
cette année ses dix ans sous cette
appellation le campus caribéen des arts
a été créé en décembre 2011 précisément
par la région martinique de l'époque
c'est un établissement public
administratif donc rattachée à la ctn la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
une fois qu'on a dit cela oudry liseron
maufils mon fils qu est-ce qu on peut
rajouter sur cet établissement assez
singulier dans le paysage de
l'enseignement supérieur en martinique
oui singulier on qu'on voudrait faire de
notre singularité une force on va dire
de notre clac itude une force aussi
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut dire sur
cette école ainsi que c'est une école
une école très jeune mais ça ne veut pas
dire du fait de son jeu nice ne serait
pas à la hauteur des écoles supérieures
d'art
il faut seulement dire que c'est une
école qui n'est pas isolé justement qui
travaillent à qualifier le lien avec
liar et ses tailleurs c'est déjà notre
voisinage et on y travaille
même si ce n'est pas toujours visible
encore et encore moins avec la crise
sanitaire qui nous concerne tous
aujourd'hui mais on y travaille a
justement à essayer de valoriser ce qui
se passe tout près de nous et ce qui se
passe au sud aussi au lointain
donc on travaille au long cours on va
dire alors c'est une école qui est situé
donc à fort de france
précisément oui c'est une école qui se
situe au quartier hermitage voilà et est
donc voilà il va falloir aussi que nous
puissions ardemment valoriser ce pôle
qui est comme une sorte de colline un
morne
on va dire ici et parce qu'il y à du
vivant il ya des gens qui habitent
il y a
donc quelque part ce sont ces le
quartier qui nous accueille c'est pas le
contraire donc on travaille à faire en
sorte que l'école puisse mieux s'ancrer
dans son quartier immédiat mais aussi à
mieux vivre le pays
pour cela il faut vraiment lancer des
ponts à droite et à gauche l'ermitage à
à fort-de-france quartier donc pour ceux
qui connaissent non loin de l'ex hôpital
civil
exactement comme on dit voilà donc du
côté de la rive nord de fort de france
on vous invite et parce que nous sommes
justement dans la période de la campagne
d'inscription est là elle commence cette
semaine du 1er mars et vous avez
organisé des journées portes ouvertes
tout récemment du 24 au 26 février
dernier oui c'est bien ça et vous
invitiez ainsi à visiter les locaux aux
jeunes à leurs parents aux uns et aux
autres vous les invitez à s'enquérir des
enseignements des programmes et vous
invitiez aussi à repartir avec l'âme
d'artiste
alors comment vous vous y êtes pris pour
parvenir à cela
alors ça c'est bien passé ses journées
portes ouvertes me semble-t-il et après
il faudrait qu'on regarde c'est en
profondeur avec notre chargé de la
communication monsieur larcher
eh bien en voilà somme toute c'est un
format qui est classique
maintenant c'est le contenu il faut
habiter est me semble-t-il les étudiants
se sont vraiment approprié ces espaces
là en tout cas cette séquence de vie au
cca au campus caribéen des arts et ce
qui est intéressant c'est d'une certaine
manière
valoriser ce qui se fait ou ce qui est
engagée aussi au sein du campus alors
les étudiants se sont vraiment prêter au
jeu et donc bien entendu une jp au
niveau des portes ouvertes c'est aussi
là pour pouvoir mettre le doigt sur là
où il faudrait encore améliorer des
choses
vous nous direz ça m'est donc l'idée
c'était de de présenter ce que ce que
font déjà les étudiants qui sont dans
l'école pour expliquer donner à voir à
ce qui serait donc intéressé pour
s'inscrire dans exactement c'est une
sorte d' amorce pour justement valoriser
l'offre pédagogique du campus 1 caribéen
des arts donc de l'école supérieure
d'art de la martinique
alors avant de parler plus précisément
du cursus des options différentes et
puis des débouchés aussi parce que c'est
important quand on se forme bon c'est
pour trouver des emplois a priori donc
l'établissement a vocation à changer de
nom bientôt c'est un projet que vous
avez ça pousse à toujours campus
caraïbes est un désert oui ça va ça va
sonner comme sur deux coupes même pas
pas vraiment depuis longtemps réfléchi à
cela la conception qu'ont pu ce n'est
pas nécessairement celles qui répondent
à ce que nous faisons et donc nous
passerons par une sensibilisation en
tout cas une concertation très élargi
par rapport à une réflexion qui
porterait sur une appellation contextuel
contextuel déjà au pays et à notre
environnement immédiat et contextuelle
aussi aux grands enjeux de la question
des questions artistiques aujourd'hui
mais vous pensez à quoi qu'est-ce qu'il
faut changer c'est là le nom de campus
pour donner quoi le non dit tu écoles
disant que nous sommes d'emblée dans un
ancrage complexe pas complexe dans le
centre ce compliqué en tout cas fait de
diversité et il me semble que la
question des amériques est fondamentale
et bien sûr et nous sommes aussi entaché
en tout cas concernés par le monde dit
européen donc le campus caribéen des
arbres pourraient porter un nom qui nous
permettrait d'être repéré par rapport à
notre voisinage déjà immédiat donc je ne
peux pas vous donner de noms mais voilà
d'accord mort de toute façon vous y
réfléchissez à ces restes comme on n'a
pas beaucoup de temps
on y va donc le cursus avec des options
option art option design avec mention
design objet plus précisément et puis
option design avec design graphique avec
aussi des cycles courts et enfin en tout
cas pour l'option arts un cycle court ou
un cycle long alors c'était trop
technique centre technique
deux options fondamentales option art et
option design
les deux options design se font relayé
par deux mentions mention design
graphique et mention design objet dont
toute l'offre pédagogique s'articule
autour de deux de ses trois 3 pôles là
on va dire qui amène à un diplôme
national d'arts
je les ai n'a jamais utilisé quand même
exactement qui amène à un dna en cycle
court ce qui est une licence et donc qui
amène on cite le 2,6 que l'on a un
master voilà toujours qui s'intitule
d'année dnsep diplôme national supérieur
d'expression plastique
alors quels sont les débouchés pour les
étudiants qui passent par cette école
supérieure d'enseignement artistique en
martinique
s'il faut parler du point de vue
contextuel nous voyons bien que nos
étudiants sont tout de suite intéressé
par les débouchés qui répondent à vivre
vivre avec ce qu'ils ont appris vettier
rapide mais voilà ça peut c'est très
légitime mais c'est peut être en fait
une orientation vers l'enseignement
une orientation vers l'idée de créer ses
propres studios où son espace
entreprenariale donc là on peut devenir
plasticiens ou de dire que l'astuce
leurs auteurs donc voilà graphiste là
ils sont sûrs et professionnellement
parlant
et puis ensuite ils peuvent aussi penser
une carrière beaucoup plus longue en
essayant de suivre toute cette espèce de
tradition liés aux résidences
artistiques conforter le réseau et et
faire en sorte qu'ils soient qu'ils
soient qu'ils aient réellement pignon
sur rue en tant que plasticien en tant
que designer alors quelques professions
à titre d'exemple en sortant de ce
campus car bien des arts
a priori on peut devenir infographiste
webdesigner par exemple mais aussi
céramiste coloriste voir auteurs et
illustrateurs pour enfants voilà donc
c'est vraiment assez variés décorateur
sénou scénographe ou encore directeur
artistique voilà si vous dire que le
goût vers des métiers qui encadre la
question artistique
la galerie ils peuvent aussi prêtant à
des cadets oui si vous voulez des études
supplémentaires
oui oui on peut devenir aussi
commissaire d'exposition et ses
positions galerie entendu alors de
manière pratique maintenant les
modalités d'inscription puisque c'est la
campagne on le rappelle comment cette
semaine c'est pas gratuit il ya quand
même des frais d'inscription je crois et
puis il ya des exonérations pour des
boursiers certaines exonérer la valeur
sociale est très importante elle même
elle préside
en tout cas c'est ce qui a animé la
création de cette école par par ses
pairs et notamment aimé césaire donc
l'idée 7 nous avons sauvegardé tout au
long de ces années là le lait frais
d'inscription l'inscription qui sont les
pubs bas frais d'inscription d'écoles
d'art supérieur et donc je veux pas vous
dire et le prix mais enfin on est bien
loin des prix astronomiques des écoles
supérieures d'art sur le pont nation il
faut compter à peu près entre 300 et 400
euros de frais ne sait combien on sent
même pas 200 euros l'accord est bon mais
il ya des frais de sécurité sociale
aussi noms qui sont accompagnés dans
leur ensemble ne sommes pas dans le
bouquet de son héros dont gwen akory
ensuite bien sûr des étudiants sont
aidés par une assistante sociale qui est
de l'école pour pouvoir trouver les
moyens de pouvoir suivre plus
sereinement leurs études
alors on n'entre pas dans le camp au
campus caribéen des arts comme dans un
moulin quand même si il faut un examen
il ya un examen d'entrée oui il ya un
examen d'entrée faut quand même qu'ils
aient ouvert donc à tout candidat
bachelier âgés de 17 à 26 ans voilà
voilà
alors c'est ce que nous disons
clairement et nous appliquons cependant
il y à une commission qui consiste à
apprécier au cas par cas aussi le
potentiel des jeunes arrivant il peut ne
pas aussi avoir le bac je ne devrais
même pas le dire mais je prends le parti
de le dire mais c'est son jour dans
cette philosophie
engagé par les pairs vous savez on est
dans le proche et il faut pas qu'on soit
rôle dans le lointain et nos étudiants
il faut qu'on soit à l écoute de ce
qu'ils veulent aussi donc les très
jeunes
nous sommes amenés à étudier les
dossiers au cas par cas aussi voilà
alors pour conclure
audry liseron monfils directeur du
campus caribéen des arts l'école
supérieure d'enseignement artistique ici
en martinique il y a une dimension
internationale aussi pour cette école
bon ben vu le nom caribéen évidemment il
ya une ouverture vers nos voisins les
plus proches mais également vous entrez
dans le cadre du dispositif erasmus
échanges européens on pouvait les
étudiants oui parfaitement
nous rentrons dans ce cadre là est et ce
qui est intéressant c'est que justement
par ce cadre là on peut créer des
variantes entre dans au niveau des
territoires qui pourrait ou des espaces
qui pourraient nous intéresser
donc c'est un travail qui est de longue
haleine et qui se poursuit encore nous
étudions notamment nous avons une
étudiante qui est parti l'an dernier à
lisbonne à l'école des beaux-arts et
université de lisbonne et elle ya passé
à la semestre d'ombré donc de plus en
plus nous aurons des profils de ce type
là n'oublions pas à côté de ce
dispositif nous avons aussi validé le
lien avec ailleurs dans la caraïbe
jamaïque notamment les étudiants yao
cette année cinq étudiants qui
normalement devrait être à l'heure au
moment où je vous parle a jamais en
jamaïque
ça n'a pas pu avoir lieu physiquement
mais nous entretenons le travail à
distance et puis et puis l'école des
beaux-arts de 2,2 du curaçao
donc ça sous-entend aussi que d'autres
structures d'autres écoles dans notre
environnement proche pourrait travailler
aussi avec nous sommes d'accord là pour
ses partenariats à l'international
donc on le rappelle on peut d'ores et
déjà télécharger en allant sur le site
du campus caribéen des z'arts le dossier
d'inscription depuis le 1er mars depuis
lundi pour donc d
des examens d'entrée qui devrait se
dérouler peut-être à la fin de ce mois
mais ce n'est pas encore certain
dans tous les cas il faut consulter le
site internet et vous en serez informés
de toute façon y'a pas de panique à bord
nous devrons encore peaufiner et la
grande thématique pour qu'on puisse
vraiment tout définir merci d'être venu
nous parler donc de cette école
supérieure d'enseignement artistique en
martinique le campus carabéen des
caraïbes et un précisément voilà des
arts certainement un sujet qui vous
intéresse aussi jimmy oui je connais
beaucoup d'amis qui sont passés par
l'intérieur là qui sont aujourd'hui des
fois photographe ou au j'aimerais bien
les accueillir encore à va bien merci et
bonne journée
[Musique]